the White House is still struggling to
contain the controversy over this week's
Helsinki summit president Trump now says
for the first time in office that he
blames Russian President Vladimir Putin
for interfering in the 2016 election the
president told CBS News that he told
Putin to stop meddling but earlier in
the day he caused more confusion by
questioning American intelligence
assessments that Russia is still
interfering with u.s. affairs is Russia
still targeting the u.s. mr. president
the White House press secretary said
later that the president was saying no
to answering more questions that he was
not second-guessing US intelligence CBS
Evening News anchor Jeff Gore as mr.
Trump directly if he held Putin
personally responsible Jeff is here now
with his new interview with the
president very curious to hear what the
president has to say Jeff all right Yael
good morning to you as our conversation
began yesterday is you all just
mentioned the White House was again
managing what appear to be controversial
comments about whether Russia is a
continuing threats but the president
told us he accepts current US
intelligence evaluations as he made this
more direct stance on Russia you say you
agree with US intelligence that Russia
meddled in the election in 2016
yeah but and I've said that before if I
have said that numerous times before and
I would say that that is true yeah but
you haven't condemned poun specifically
do you hold him personally responsible
well I would because he's in charge of
the country just like I consider myself
to be responsible for things that happen
in this country so certainly as the
leader of a country you would have to
hold him responsible yes what you said
to him a very strong on the fact that we
can't have meddling we can't have any of
that now look we're also living in a
grown-up world we'll a strong statement
you know President Obama supposedly made
a strong statement nobody heard it what
they did here is the statement he made
to Putin his very close friend and that
statement was not acceptable didn't get
very much play relatively speaking but
that said it was not acceptable but I
let him know we can't have this
we're not going to have it and that's
the way it's going to be we had a very
strong meeting on so many different
points and you know and I've said and I
campaigned on it getting along with
Russia and China by the way and other
countries is a very good thing not a
very bad thing but he denies it so if
you believe US intelligence agencies is
Putin lying to you I don't want to get
into whether or not he's lying I can
only say that I do have confidence in
our intelligence agencies as currently
constituted I think that dan coats is
excellent I think the Gena is excellent
I think we have excellent people in the
agencies and when they tell me something
it means a lot coach says the threat is
ongoing do you agree with that well I'd
accept him I mean he's an expert this is
what he does he's been doing a very good
job I have tremendous faith in dan
coates
and if he says that I would accept that
I will tell you though it better not be
it better not be have you talking a code
since you got back yeah I have sure what
do you say just talk generally speaking
yeah he agrees with the statement you
made and I go along with him
he's a very it's a great guy he's a
great Patriot
he loves this country and he's only
gonna say what he truly believes and the
information that's given to him is that
do you think any intelligence agencies
US intelligence agencies are out to get
you well certainly in the past it's been
terrible you look at Brennan you look at
clapper you look at Hayden you look at
Comey you look at McCabe you look at
struck and his lover
Lisa page you look at other people in
the FBI that have been fired that are no
longer there certainly I can't have any
confidence in the past but I can have a
lot of confidence in the present in the
future because it's getting to be now
where we're putting our people in but in
the past no I have no confidence in a
guy like Brennan I think he's a total
lowlife I have no confidence in clapper
you know clapper wrote me a beautiful
letter
when I first went to office and it was
really nice and then all of a sudden
he's gone haywire because they got to
him and they probably got him to say
things that maybe he doesn't even mean
but no I certainly don't have confidence
in past people you look at what's
happened take a look at all of the
shenanigans that have gone on very hard
to have confidence in that group on
Saturday you told us your doctrine is
strength and achieving peace through
strength
right after Helsinki Lindsey Graham said
you showed weakness let me just i
totally disagree I think I did great at
the news conference I think it was a
strong news conference you have people
that said you should have gone up to him
you should have walked up and started
screaming in his face we're living in
the real world okay nobody's been as
tough with Putin as I have you look at
all of the other things that I've done
with respect to Russia that nobody else
has done including sanctions sanctions
the biggest sanctions ever imposed on
Russia it's just a fake news deal they
love this narrative even you you're
wasting a lot of time talking about
Russia nobody has been tougher on Putin
and on Russia than Donald Trump it is
top of mind that's why we asked about it
the president also spoke about the 20/20
election telling us more about his plans
and who his dream opponents would be
we're gonna have much more on that guys
in our next hour your next hour you stay
at the table tonight 70% of the American
people according to our new CBS News
poll believe that the they are on the
side of US intelligence believe that
Russian interfere do you think the
president is there why had a hesitation
where is he I mean we know what he said
I think there that there's traditionally
been this tendency to to group both
collusion and meddling in the same right
and I think there's an attempt by folks
around him to separate those two and
that is there could be meddling but
maybe not collusion saying one way or
the other
but he made
that distinction on Tuesday he made that
distinction again yesterday it's
interesting yesterday that he didn't go
into that there was no collusion riff I
mean he stayed focused on answering your
question about what he said to Putin and
when he said he'd better not be that was
the strongest he's been I think so far
well I did ask him about about the
special counsel and whether he'd sit and
when I went there the first thing he
said about that was no collusion okay
I've never heard him say why he wanted
to have a private meeting to begin with
did he give you any details about any
more details about what was discussed in
the private meeting it seems like we
would have eliminated a lot of this a
lot of this conversation if if the
meeting had been open and people could
see exactly what was being said he don't
know what to believe well he mentioned
three things he mentioned nuclear
weapons he mentioned Israel and he
mentioned North Korea I asked him for
specifics on some of those he didn't
provide many specifics the White House
has not put a readout out we may not get
one since it was just those two in the
room and the translators but I do think
that there is a belief from this
president that whether it's kim
jeong-hoon or vladimir putin or someone
else that he wants to be in a room with
someone talking to someone that's right
all right Jeff we're gonna have more
later